morning millenials oh that felt good
except I got sued good morning Jackie
good morning Claudia it has been six
years that cracks really six he was
three months since he sat in his chairs
and I really I've missed it but I've
enjoyed my time off thoroughly well I
enjoyed my actual time off when I wasn't
here because I was diverted to
Pittsburgh I wasn't necessarily like
joyous no but it was a divine diversion
so so much has happened since we last
spoke but we also released a podcast
episode yesterday recapping a lot of the
things that we needed to recap because
now us talking about the CMA is like
homegirl that was six years ago you know
that was so long ago and if you want the
full recap it's already up on the
podcast app for me as a patron episode
so if you're a peach remember you knew
all this a week ago if you are a patreon
member you got for premium ass episodes
this week we were being so funny while
we were away in Utah and your fifth
episode is coming today because I'm
gonna film the behind the scenes vlog of
my dreams coming true they're going to
the Blue Bloods head today which is why
this show is at 9:30 a.m. today for Tom
Sal I read such a funny comment so I was
like lol Claudia meek and Jackie wake up
so she could go to a show the jacket
doesn't watch yeah yeah but that's here
yeah that's gonna rest you are
professional professional courteous yes
whatever Deborah would never
double-booked never I can't hear you
because I have mucus in my ear it's so
crazy it's like this and it just
happened maybe like 20 minutes ago you
really can't miss oh sometimes when you
like fly your ears like get yeah but
it's usually right after the plane they
like never one time my ears were didn't
pop for days it's gone and no it's not
it's not hold your nose and blow out
there's mucus my hair of course Jackie I
did that already
no okay well every moment on the show
today is precious because we have about
an hour for the show because sisters
have to leave snitch is here today being
snitchy as usual cinchy that is a blouse
if I've ever seen it and then except you
let her it's a blouse sweat and well
because I'm dressing up for Tom I mean
I'm wearing a [ __ ] turtleneck for Tom
and lucky loafers okay I only have
respect for Tom Selleck you guys look
really sorry did I mention where we're
going oh yeah okay so me Berger gonna
set of Blue Bloods I'm very excited I
brought everyone Murch also my merch is
available shop girl with no job comm if
you didn't get it yet it shipped so fast
everyone already has and it's so cute we
did a little photo shoot oh yeah and
it's premium cell Utah was so premium we
have to recap Utah just for a minute
because your jaw is slowly bending my
favorite state it might be the seat for
me and you know what's so funny it's
like it's the Mormon State and it's even
if you're not women you're talking about
Mormon it's like all the cab drivers
like you Mormon I'm like now are you
know but we talked about beef yeah okay
do you know there's a Mormon toasters
group the Mormon toast oh my god I don't
have anything of Mormon I think in Mykel
Oh same especially like Salt Lake City
Mormons yeah no it's a very Mormon vibe
there yeah except we didn't see we
didn't meet one Mormon no which is easy
but I look forward to it I mean I want
to meet the sister wives Cody and his
wives and if those aren't the Mormons
I'm meeting I'm not interested in
meeting any others know it at Mike
happening oh yeah Mykelti oh yeah oh
there's a lot of like famous Mormons no
one Mitt Romney was gonna be the first
Mormon president yeah that would be wild
who else is a Mormon I bet there's
Google famous Mormons celebrity Mormons
all I can think of is Book of Mormon and
why isn't there like a like a Carl Lentz
are like a famous priest from the Mormon
community I think that there is our cab
driver was telling us about one of the
new church leader and then all I think
of is uh Joseph Smith and Brigham Young
hello my name is elder price the woman
who wrote Twilight is Mormon hmm if you
remember Glenn Beck he was Mormon was is
and then Bill Marriott I'm assuming has
to do and Mary Osmond nobody hurry are
you Mary Wow that's you're really
showing your age Margo Margo did you
join this do you know I did I did not
eligible you invited me so I thought I
was alone there was a new toaster sub
group called the Steen he vibes and the
teens cat paws and it was so cute this
girl wrote in the toasters laissez Jews
like is anyone else in high school and
like all these women
I know but then there was like a couple
hundred who were toasty high-schoolers
another in a group together and I needed
to be in that group just to stay
relevant know same like guys answering
the questions I was like damn I'm 26
yeah we need to get that it like that
group poppin and like one of our biggest
subgroups because they are the future of
this show also apparently a lot of the
Dancing with the Stars pros are Mormon
like Whitney who you saw in the airport
we support our Leon Huff might be Mormon
she would have come up in my research
yeah she's super feat whatever you
taught was just so light and honestly
like I said this time on of the patreon
episodes but the liquor stores they're
our government regulated like they're
not open on Sundays they have certain
hours and the government controls it and
it's just like it's so crazy because
that it's like the laws are so different
it really felt like I was in the
different country because I stepped onto
a plane and entered into a new land so
so now you're comfortable saying it
nobody's been comfortable saying it's a
true phrase I just never said it and by
the way it's such a wise phrase I should
take credit for it but I'm not because
they didn't say it but you know we said
at the same time anyways also I'm
laughing hello from our patreon ever
said we happen to talk about Roden
fields which we never talk about because
they're torture or anything oh I know
why we talk about it because I've burned
off all my eyelashes and I try to go in
apparently wrote in Fields does have it
does serum and I'm afraid to say it but
I need the lash serum so please don't
attack me but just someone give me a
link thank you like camp bars should
send you a link and then there's all the
says hello have you heard of her hello
my name is wrote in for you I'm at hnup
those were so good this month I highly
encourage you guys to sign up if you can
yeah because even though we're back
there's so much premium content we
didn't episode the four of us which has
never been done before and probably will
never be done again no cuz we never got
stop fighting and we're never in the
same place at the same time like ever
but after you get through the first
three minutes of fighting there really
is premium content and we figured out
the organization the flow of it all yes
we did what else we went skiing so CJ
snitch and I I was counting that was my
fifth time skiing in my life same I
think you're a little more know ice we
skied twice last time yeah i seed twice
with zach and i seed once with my
friends i was just this was six and
seven days they seventh day skiing of my
and I just have to say like I'm I'm
killing it
now you guys are really good and like
it's really just a testament to like
your build being so athletic because I
tried it once last year and like just
getting to the slopes alone was like
enough to make sure I would never go
back ya know a tractor you buy boots the
skis are so long it's a stupid it's
really won the first day it's absolutely
worse because one time I went skiing
with my friends I don't even count this
in my seven days where they just like
threw me on skis and put me on the
slopes with them cuz I was like I don't
want to eat a lesson cuz I'm right
I was anti less and I was so wrong that
was my big mistake huge so they were
like okay come with us flying down the
mountain like out the only way into the
stop was to fall and so I fell and then
after like three times of doing that I
just took my C's off and walk down the
mountain and sat at the lodge and I was
like I'm never ever doing this and I was
literally you and then I had an amazing
instructor once and it changed
everything I'm just like I'm so
uninterested in getting and just hanging
I can't tell you enough much more until
the logy vibes with like hot chocolate
and every snack you can imagine we ate
our way through Utah like truly I don't
remember a time in my life even before I
became like the skinny person that I am
where I ever just like so recklessly ate
whatever was in my way like this week
was seven days of pure eating like I
there wasn't a moment where I walked
past the kitchen and it didn't just grab
a double stuffed Oreo like it was so
crazy and I when I got home I was like I
have to weigh myself because really the
only way to shock your brain back into
like getting on track is to weigh
yourself agree and I did it this morning
and I lost a pound how is that possible
I'm mega scale hope no that really gives
me hope I don't know how that's possible
we ate so much and like between Olivia
and Ben like someone was cooking for us
at every like hardcore meals and we have
a ton of maybe like 30 pounds of kosher
meat shipped to our house like we didn't
know I think it was like a hundred
pounds jegi we didn't want for anything
no and it's like if I ever came to a
minute where I was like hungry which
never happened so I was never hungry but
if I ever did it was like filthy some
table feet see vibes tacos chicken
stir-fry
tacos burgers yes
tacos were just everything yes now that
I know that Ben knows how to make tacos
so well like we're having tacos
I had no idea I [ __ ] love tacos but I
only like tacos like made the kosher way
in our house like I don't like talked
about I've never been to talk about
salmon like I don't think I would like a
taco from like just Taurus or Chipotle
or like I just know I just want kosher
tacos no homemade tacos
yeah with just like a shell what's that
bring or not like the Vanderpump Bros
kids having to go to the Taco Bell
Factory
right like they live for Tom Ortega
we're taking I like an Ortega shell with
kosher ground beef with a little taco
seasoning and a couple egg whites you're
so healthy no that's the thing about
being so skinny like me it's like health
is just in my blood well anyways now
everything for the rest of the week will
be smelling like campfire because oh my
god oh it's nice to make hair irons my
makeup brushes smells like fire because
I had a fireplace in my room oh yeah so
everything is just bursting you know
what it's just a reminder of the good
times I had with my family good memory
never want I I'm happy to be reminded of
it every minute of every day um so yeah
if you're looking for more recaps of si
mas head over to our podcast episode
from yesterday but if you're looking for
premium content stay tuned because here
are the Fast Five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast okay
first story everyone's talking about
Amanda Bynes on the cover of paper Mac's
owner garage
is opening up about her drug fueled
spirals so amanda Bynes break the
internet it's like do they not have
another copywriter that they can't think
of something I thought that was weird
that they repurposed it but like they
did make it up right but they're it's
two completely different like Kim was
breaking the internet with her ass and
the other Bynes is just breaking the
internet and I don't know that this is
breaking the internet it's just like
amanda Bynes like breaking your
childhood paper magazines sometimes it's
like so on the ball this is so on the
ball just that one line I just I felt
like we could have done better
yes see no I agree maybe they went
through all the options and they
couldn't it seems what I say I hadn't
thought I haven't thought of anything
better yet but like it could have been
like Amanda Bynes
my favorite scooter you know like
something better I mean here's this
could a man behind her favorite scooter
yeah amanda Bynes hold on
amanda Bynes word g---men
and the Bynes manner whom that that
would have been perfect I think that
just would open it all up or amanda
bynes Moody's point period amanda Bynes
bring in the dancing officers oh please
that's it
look it took us ten seconds to get there
for you but you don't even know my god
forbid paper magazine hires us right so
just so you know we just gave you six
amazing option here wait someone said
they have a break the internet special
every year Oh like it's like the
September issue would they break the
internet is hey that's kind of cool was
Kim the first day obviously not cool
enough that none of us knew about it
yeah but I'm the first one I don't know
she was clearly the first one to break
it right they attempt once a year
different games had to reboot because
Kim Kardashian broke the interwebs
totally okay here's the story amanda
bynes quote never liked the taste of
alcohol and found marijuana to be her
bicep choice quote I started smoking
mary j when I was 16 even though
everyone thought I was the good girl
wait can I see somebody look this is
gonna be hundred or so because people
like who want to legalize and I have no
stake on either side I don't really care
people who want to legalize marijuana I
like okay again I know people who are
against it are like it's a gateway drug
and are they and then people who are pro
it they're like no it's not but Amanda
Bynes might be proof that it's a gateway
drug that's all I'm saying even though
everyone thought I was the quote good
girl I did smoke marijuana from that
point on the former child star revealed
and paper magazine's annual break the
internet issue okay I guess we shouldn't
just read the article no that was more
fun yeah quote I didn't get addicted
then and I wasn't abusing it and I
wasn't going out and partying or making
fool of myself yet she continued yeah
while Bynes now 32 expend experimented
with quote Molly and ecstasy quote I
tried cocaine three times but I never
got high from cocaine she learned more
about adderall after reading an article
in a magazine around the time she
appeared in hairspray which opened in
2007 oh my god I keep being reminded of
her precious work no it's so upsetting
portfolio so that's so impressive
quote they were talking about how women
were taking it to stay thin I was like
well I have to get my hands on that well
I have to get my hands on that but said
later obtaining a prescription after
visiting a psychiatrist and faking the
symptoms of a DD vines recalled how
quote cheese to chew the
at all tablets in her trailer while
filming 2010's Hall Pass I remember
chewing on a bunch of them and literally
being scatterbrained and not being able
to focus on my lines or memorize them
for that matter vine said it was the
mixture being so high that I couldn't
remember my lines and not liking my
appearance that led to her dropping out
of the film what I made a bunch of
mistakes but I wasn't fired I did leave
it was definitely completely
unprofessional of me to walk off and
leave them stranded when they spend so
much money on a set and crew and a
camera and equipment and everything she
stated what movie was this for Hall Pass
then that girl from Baywatch alexandra
daddario got the part so she's making
curse write the release of 2010's eza
also triggered by the spiral quote I
literally couldn't stand my appearance
in that movie and I didn't like my
performance I was absolutely convinced I
needed to stop acting after seeing she
said quote I was high on marijuana when
I saw that but for some reason it really
started to affect me I don't know if he
was a drug induced psychosis or what but
it affected my brain in a different way
than it affects other people it
absolutely changed my perception of
things so this is a really long article
retailing coke rehab she got to where
she was because I feel like like I don't
know the way that I think of it this
like actors like never watch their own
work and I was like if I was an actress
I could never watch it cuz like those
angles in my chin like no way but this
is like almost relatable this is
unbelievably relating to my mental
health deteriorated because I hated the
way that I looked in certain movies and
like I kind of feel that and she hated
the way she performed as well and even
though I love DC I thought she was
amazing in and I never would have
thought twice about it now singing back
on it it was definitely one of her more
obnoxious characters but I understand
how she might have taken
she might have not liked it I don't
think that was her fault I think that
was the writing I can't explain it
though like her just being so lucid is
so important and I think if she could
turn it around completely like not only
could she revamp what could have been
like the greatest acting career
seriously of our generation also come
comedic Talent she was funny she wrote
like she was involved like homeland
she was doing a one-woman SNL show oh
she invented SNL sweetie look it up
sweetie
like I don't know I think it's really
and I think she holds the keys to a lot
of the Dan Schneider corruption and I
think her getting back into the swing of
things being sober being like lucid is
one of the most important things that
could potentially happen in 2019
to say yeah so I'm I'm so happy for her
she looks amazing she sounds great great
on the cover and I just want the best
for her and so just let us know once
again what we can do to help you if that
means to not talk about you totally to
do it if it means I'm leavin on a wedge
show like before paper magazine so if
you do want a platform to come on that
is totally supportive of you and you're
working your brand please you're always
welcome here on the morning shows and
supportive of whatever you choose to do
next whether it is to continue your
phenomenal acting career or to pivot
towards fashion which is she's in school
right now for fashion also something
interesting that we posted on our
Instagram from the article is that she
said when they were casting she's the
man what's the same Channing Tatum came
in to audition and nobody liked him and
he didn't have any experience he
commercial they thought it was too old
and amanda Bynes was like no I'm telling
you like the girls are gonna love him
and she cast him and gave him a career
so you're welcome Channing Tatum Thank
You Amanda Bynes for your gifts that
keep on giving truly okay so much mucus
in my ears I think I've just transferred
it now to this year Wow okay move around
the same ite to make a little more sense
it's a it's a disease called might maybe
some years I mean you know supper every
year this folks person I think I'm good
hello okay 10 Japan
okay next story speaking of scripts that
are not in tune with what's necessary
whatsoever Kim Cattrall Sex in the City
three story line involved Miranda's
teenage son you guys this story is viola
Hastings mooning you very good and for
the first time ever I am on Kim Cattrall
side oh this isn't the first time but
this is the first time where I'm putting
my foot down I'm saying dresses for Kim
Cattrall and I'm seeing everything so
clearly the plot cuz for a while I
really didn't know I was like inching
towards her side but I didn't know
because you know Andy Cohen loved Sarah
Jessica Parker but and she led a little
a Russian how could she be a monster
totally totally the plot thickens is
Newton but this has nothing to do with
Sarah Jessica Parker anyway so she's
gonna get out of this one unscathed
the plot thickens his new details emerge
about the cancelled Sex in the City
three movie a source close to the
project is revealing to e-news what led
to the demise of the highly anticipated
third installment
I'm just letting you guys know like no
one's anticipating this nobody expected
no and no one wants ya hang up the
Manolos ladies Oh God
hang up the kitten heels it is time to
go home according to The Insider it
wasn't just bigs all-consuming death
that discouraged Kim Cattrall from
signing on for the third movie which we
need to talk about as well because that
being a plotline is [ __ ] horrible we
had to suffer through 10 years of her
letting a man she so desperately did not
deserve and then her killing him to no
right pay disparities and the script as
a whole discouraged her from signing
like she was making less yeah
quote Kim never wanted to really do the
movie to begin with the source reveals
it was a combination of not great money
and a bad storyline for Samantha it was
a bad script the source puts it simply
what made the script so bad you may ask
well for starters set Samantha's main
storyline revolved around her and
Miranda's 14 year-old son Brady early in
the film Brady gets caught masturbating
he's also caught sending dick pics of
his erect penis to Samantha Chuck just
last week artisans host James Andrew
Miller revealed that the third movie
would have seen the death of big carries
husband ultimately making the film
center around SJ peas character Oh
Miller said that this urged katrell
since the movie would have been more
about how Carrie recovers from big stat
then about the relationship between the
four and women oh no yeah the whole time
she's crying in Mexico that was torture
no wait to do that again right I'm an
even higher scale because like call
enough wedding is way better than a
death come up with a new formula for a
movie like and also why so they're only
in good times in between movies you know
they're like we don't get to see it a
movie starts and everything is terrible
yeah but I just want to watch them being
happy going to lunch and shopping total
war over Kim feels that Sex in the City
simply isn't relatable anymore quote I
think the climate changed to have four
women talking about shopping trips and
spending $400 on shoes when people are
having trouble putting food on the table
less use me it doesn't mean we don't be
less means it's true it doesn't mean we
don't need that but I think that the
pendulum swung in a different direction
I kind of agree it's like none of the
women really worked and it's like we're
supposed to like want to have Kerry's
life when she is a [ __ ] nag and a
half and lands a rich man and really
stops working like I'm good also like
this storyline
Brady and his erect penis like I'm
shipped in the [ __ ] Corps also
like I love Samantha she's gorgeous at
any age but she's 60 years old and then
when a 14-year old is like just coming
into his own like I don't know that a
six-year-old is the first person he's
sending pictures to and if it is we've
got a Houston we have a problem and
Jackie who's the fourteen-year-old
redheaded who's playing Brady that's
what we need to figure out happy Mason
Ramsey Oh Jackie I guess the actor is
now 14 yeah you know would have been
good they seemed uneven you know who
would have been good one of the twins
who played in Lynette's kids it's only
you because Charles Charlie it's only
ill because of the story that they wrote
of course but stop he's not 13 he's 12
okay but maybe or 14 they give you like
a 16 year old okay yeah like those twins
what are they be someone from the
stranger things I don't watch it's like
so gross
honestly Millie Bobby brought him to
find a way to play it like she would
become a man people are freaking out
about how gross to say I mean no no then
give them a you made it gross I'm sorry
Mason was just mad you are not
protecting it I'll call someone who I
know well you know what like I'm just
salty if he didn't come through on the
red carpet for us anyways Jesse's for me
too Jackie
thank you just as for Kim Cattrall I'm
officially and completely on her side
because everything she says makes a lot
of sense and so her being so in tune on
this makes me think that she's right
about the other stuff you know about the
bullying on set and then I totally oh
and the move early of it all by the way
you won't hear an interesting factoid
speaking of sex
I love interesting factoids I've been
wearing the same bra since Nashville Wow
it's my third love bra because like I
just usually the only reason I changed
bras these days is due to sweat yes I
haven't sweat in my in my third right we
were in a cold climate
we are you wearing that the rate during
the divine diversion yes of course oh my
god the divine diversion I was wearing
the same clothes the entire time on the
airplane it was like so not good I love
my clothes from the Divine version stand
up straight now yes but when I got home
yesterday I was like getting undressed
like damn I'm wearing this bra since
Nashville Wow I mean that's their love
for you that comfort and that you don't
even realize
sometimes I have to like Cheerilee like
peel it off when it's like a bra but
this one just slid right off also did
you see third love put an ad in the New
York Times from their CEO directly
addressing Victoria's Secret now what
did they say it was just like so Wells
read but like she little shot a and I
love that because in the interview they
mention third love I guess their love is
like a really big competitor for them I
mean I think aware their bras for two
weeks in a row right and you go online
you fill out a profile a boob profile
which is just the best thing go file and
I recommend that everyone do it because
their comfort their understanding of a
woman's shape and I don't think there's
an parallel there aren't two better
people to endorse a bra than us because
I have been through so many bras I used
to have to travel to to the ends of the
earth to find bras a fit and I'm just
looking for a bra that holds and
separates is that so hard
also they carry cups from A through H
and bands up to 48 like thank you thank
you so home girl is not that small and
fro third love knows there's a perfect
bra for everyone so right now they're
offering our listeners 15% off your
first order go to 3rd Lib comm slash
morning toast now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off your first
purchase
that's third love.com slash morning
toast for 15% off today so worth it you
guys and an amazing price point for a
broad that you won't take off truly
great story great great Thank You Kim
Cattrall for bringing the truth to the
surface
speaking of Kim's Kim Kardashian xsa oh
oh that well I just picked any Kim
Kardashian story so that we could talk
about what the Kardashians have been
able to in the past two weeks and
clearly it's ecstasy Kim Kardashian and
Kanye West called obnoxious and wasteful
for flying on a private empty empty 747
oh my god people will find anything okay
if you watch him stories her and Kanye
flee want a private 747 so a 747 is like
the type of plane you take to Israel
right and a 747 can't go fast enough
Lady Antebellum you know it you don't
know what song 747 it's called 740 yet
I've never even seen bird oh my god o
sing about the story this morning look
it up sweetie
yeah it's called music look it up
sweetie
I'm snitch man thank you for a tissue
I'm like melting you did not come
prepared I'm sorry I bet I have in my
purse
I bought some facial tissues like those
little packets I felt like an actual six
year old six r66
oh my god it's just really dripping
thank you snitch here pass it to me oh
there's oh wow okay get your [ __ ] I'm
sorry everyone close your ears okay oh
girl just hang on
I hope you mean tutor Mike thank you and
I'll just cover I'll just talk into mine
so that okay are you ready now are you
ready for the Kardashian portion of
today's show yes okay Kim and Kanye if
you watch your stories flew on a sir
private 747 which most people including
myself did not know existed nor did I
ever even think about it I knew that it
existed because I believed that P Diddy
has one right that's what you were
saying and so it's unclear where they
went did we ever find out did they fly
anywhere yes they flew somewhere really
far they kept saying that's why they had
to bring their trainer on and do lunges
down the aisles but this jet was paid
for by adidas so it wasn't their money
being wasteful if you want to blame
someone blame adidas but I just think
this is so cool one like that this
exists and to that she's showing us like
most of us will never go on a private
747 in our entire lives and now we get a
glimpse into it it's like that show that
we used to watch like secret lives of
the yeah whatever it's yeah like that's
so cool I found it's so interesting
totally are learning about aviation yeah
capabilities okay also like is that what
Air Force One is yeah definitely okay
that's what I thought the plane was so
big like when I saw it he had like a gut
like his the belly had a plane the plane
had a belly like it was so crazy I was
just loving being a part of it there was
a [ __ ] full fledge of bedroom okay
but I'm gonna say something like a
little controversial and some of the
toaster said it too and that made me
think of it it wasn't done ice it was
like very retro no just like the design
was like a little bland a little bland
like they just put so many seats in it
it's like if you a private suit I'm
already seven like you could put a
swimming pool like you could do crazy
stuff you could have it like made of all
windows and just look at the sky and
snap you got your counselor that would
way cool you know so I just felt like it
wasn't a must've been like from the 80s
or something you know it just looked
like it definitely looked dated yeah
but having said that I would still take
it at any time Oh any time
just 18 I don't know it seemed like for
a lot of people you know yeah it was
just the two of them and the trainer and
I'm sure their crew like I think I saw
Mario there up okay ooh I think I heard
Jonathan in the background
did you I don't know I mean yeah that's
so cool so cool anyway so the current
takes care of her crow I mean she really
does and I love how like she's Kim
Kardashian and they're still like things
that she can be amazed by like a private
747 and like we saw in this past week
share
she was Dan girling so cute for share ma
she was in the car with her friends on
the way to the concert she was talking
about meeting chef she's met chair once
before but she was talking about what
she was gonna say to her the way you
were talking about what you were gonna
say to her at gift of life gala so I
just I think she's just so cute and I
love her and I just love it
she's the biggest art of the world but
there's still things that she's
impressed by these old things in people
yeah it's like sad though that like the
thing that gets her impressed is a
private 747 which is something most of
us didn't even know existed up until
yesterday but when it went when she
started posting more glitter text me
she's like oh look a Kim Kardashian
stories I'm like what no and one market
market was like do you see that she flew
up a private 747 I was like like what I
didn't really I was like I didn't know
that I cared until I saw it so I use
that certainly private jets that were
the size of commercial airplanes but I
thought was a commercial airplane it's
like three seats on each side that take
you to Miami like not full fledge eLAL
to Israel I don't even know if I've been
on the 747 now looking at how bad that
plane is you've been on it to Israel
you've been on it to look not to LA no
and like not to Florida so it only have
to be to Israel yeah that's so crazy so
crazy anyways she also revealed on last
week's episode people are freaking that
she used to be a wild party girl and she
was on ecstasy during her first marriage
like during her first wedding soon and
when she filmed her sex tape yeah and
she was like you could see in the video
my jaw shaking and I have seen the video
not who I was not looking at her job but
next time I will take a better look
I have not seen the video so I could not
speak to it but I believed her okay so I
saw the video when I was in high school
and there was a boy in my grade I went
to fame him because he's a nice boy do
you know what is my girl yeah I want to
know don't do it no and he's a nice boy
and he has a lot of sisters and I'm not
gonna shoot him but what I really want
to say it was easy but what did he get
he had it on his computer
oh and he showed it to me in the lounge
and I was like it was like the first
like porn I ever saw and I was like but
it was like the edited version with her
like walking in the Bluebird
very like bikini like doing great dance
and then it's cut up with like you know
her sucking Ray J's song along so um it
was quite artistic but I didn't notice
the job but I'll take a better luck next
time
and what's so crazy so if she wasn't on
ecstasy she wouldn't I mean the sex tape
is what she said cuz she said all my bad
decisions came from it's the master
agent maybe she wouldn't have made a sex
tape and then like would she be who she
is if not for ecstasy
no that's really crazy to say thank you
drugs oh so she's just like so she's
just so cute even when she's talking
about ecstasy like she's being cute I
just feel like for a while she was so
protective of like her image and her
brown like she never would've admitted
to this like on her own show but now
she's just so comfortable and like her
level of Fame and like who she is and
her family like she's great and she like
with post pictures I'd like to throw
back pics of them and I feel like for a
while she was like ashamed of her past
but now she's really embracing it
because she can do whatever she wants
and I just love her all the more for it
it's kind of hell like when you're a mom
or like when you're in your 20s and 30s
like your kids are your life and like
your kids your kids and then you come
forward and the kids were growing up
like you have your second life again
like him is having her second life your
other kids are still like six your no
yet these are her golden years for sure
which really like makes me because
people we say like your most beautiful
in your 20s that's your prime you know
physically mentally whatever but like
the Kardashians are really uh pending
that say like a famous till they were
like thirty right and Kourtney's almost
40 and like she's out here in the clubs
in her bathing suit she's almost 40
right that gosh she's on the covers with
you and like so ugly as much as she's so
annoying like she looked amazing she's
doing like a lot for at forty year old I
couldn't grade never thought of it that
way but she's got to find a new
boyfriend him and his little goatee like
I want to I don't even know who her
boyfriend is because I don't follow that
Mucca Mucca Shabbat she came there was
news last week that she came out to say
that she's not pregnant cuz there was
speculation that she was a news posted a
picture and she's like there's been a
lot of second this vide new said there's
been a lot of speculation that Kourtney
and Scott are pregnant she's taken the
rumors head-on I've never even heard the
second I never heard any another type of
person who would hear it and like
perpetuate it right cuz and that's also
a story like I would cheer for because I
I'm ready for them to have another times
he said they tried and couldn't oh
because they both want a fourth like
with the same parents but that they
couldn't did they try how I believe with
like a turkey baster
okay that's sad though good they like I
hope that they have success that would
be so cute
also Khloe's birth
um Eric Kardashian Kardashian's and it
really was so it was premium content it
was a little anticlimactic
with the drama but the drama is so real
and they like we really get to see like
behind the scenes like what's going on
what they're saying what they're feeling
like it's really crazy it is really
crazy and I don't know what I did when
Kim went on Ellen and she said it's so
[ __ ] up and that was like a story here
we're talking about Kim and then came
like new and she they called Chloe
like it's crazy it is crazy I don't know
why I just expected like a real soap
opera acting from them and like when Kim
was like I'm gonna kill him and she gets
to the room and she's just like behind
us back me up
she keeps feeling like that like that's
not that dramatic like I would suck a
bit job sacks grandma loves Kardashians
and she was just watching that episode
and then she came to dinner and she kept
going like this it was rad buzz cuts
jokes yeah Rises a toaster - so if she's
watching okay next story really like I'm
so invested in for my little sister does
it feel like this is our eleventh story
well yes because in each story we're
talking about the same category anytime
that person was mentioned in the past
two weeks yeah this story I'm invested
in for my little sister Shawn Mendes
constantly feels the need to quote prove
that he's not gay how many times will
Shawn Mendes have to say he's not gay
for people to believe him the 20 year
old Canadian star emphasized his
heterosexuality in Rolling Stones
December issue and discussed the
constant stress he feels living his life
in the spotlight quote I'd like to say I
don't care about it but that's not true
he said before adding quote this massive
massive thing for the last five years
about me being gay Mendes is sexuality
has been a topic of conversation ever
since in my blood singer launched to
start him in 2014 last Christmas he
finally reached the boiling point after
reading comments on YouTube about his
sexuality he took to snapchat to address
the public quote I noticed a lot of
people were saying I gave them quote a
gay vibe first of all I'm not gay
second of all it shouldn't make a
difference if I was or wasn't but the
rumors continued to circulate which has
affected how Mendes conducts himself in
public or earlier this year for example
tour mate and friend Taylor Swift sent
Mendes a picture this part really showed
me sent men is a picture of the two of
them together to make sure he was okay
with her posting it the picture was of
the two of them backstage at her
reputation tour and Swift applying
glitter eyeshadow to Mendez his face at
first Mendes was okay with her posting
it but later on he got paranoid quote he
felt I felt sick he told
zyne I was like [ __ ] why did I let her
post post that I just fed the fire that
I'm terrified of elsewhere he added in
the back of my heart I feel like I need
to go be seen with someone like a girl
in public able to prove that I'm not gay
even though in my heart I know that it's
not a bad thing there's still a piece of
me that thinks that and I hate that side
of me recently he was linked to model
Haley Baldwin of their relationship he
said I don't even want to put a title on
it I think it was more of a zone of
limbo it didn't last of course and she
got engaged she doesn't me they were
Bieber a month later I thought this
whole thing was so sad like it really
made me feel bad for like a little
letter I call him like like gay in my
clothes like a million times like I feel
really bad cuz it's like he's literally
talking about me and like this just
proves like celebrities are human and
like I'm gonna stop like speculating
that he's gay and like who cares if he
is or he isn't but like it made me
really sad I don't know I felt really
badly and yeah I just feel like he was
talking to me and by the by Judy's
Instagram he put the cover and he was
like I wish more of the article had made
it in cuz I guess like once they started
talking about this this is all the
writer cared about because she got the
story right but I feel like I'm sure
there was even more that he said and he
and he probably feels like they just
took like sound bikes but I do feel like
he came off very fair aspect fold and I
understand what he's saying and any I
think it was really respect no he was
very honest and that but I'm sure that
there's even more that would make us
like feel more endear toward him and
that he was even more considerate and
full of what he was saying but I don't
feel like he came off badly at all no no
not at all the Taylor Swift thing that
like took me and Mike were coz like
first of all if Taylor wants to post
something like I thought she just posted
know she like asks permission that's so
nice
second of all like you know that feeling
like if someone says you could post
something in there like yeah and then
like I literally want to die yeah and he
just makes me like rethink everything
because I you he was just one of those
people that it was just like almost like
an open secret it felt like you know
right like everyone's talking about it
he'll he won't admit it for whatever
reason and now with making me think of
other people who we say the same thing
about who probably are you know what
really reminds me of it reminds me manic
Jonas as I was saying other people who
are getting married on December 1st I
don't really like I don't feel that way
about Nick Jonas anymore like for a
while I was like oh he's a 100% guy and
like it's just a matter of time it's
like he doesn't have to come out or
anything it's like it's just cool
whatever and that's how I felt about
Sean minutes and I thought that about
the same now I don't feel that way about
Nick Jonas at all I just don't think
he's really in love with Priyanka but
that's totally separate separate but by
the way they're getting married like
as we speak the way he started on
Tuesday it's about day wedding so I
can't believe it so it'll be over on
Saturday I think that they're gonna have
a very long and happy marriage I think
so long I'm not that happy who know
they're happy because they're being
thirsty and it's working and it's really
really working and I just can't believe
I just can't believe it
it goes against everything that I ever
thought to be true like same I just
can't believe it like of all the
engagements this year like they have
made it down the aisle Hurst who
actually aliens okay but there was no
accepted City Hall yeah they do and you
get like big bouquet I don't know I'm
kind of like loving them loving like
they're very happy in Toronto she is
looking so glad she's literally the crew
she's like the level of Fame she's
always wanted to be in America in
Toronto now no and in America too and
she doesn't have to lift a finger except
Margot notice an interesting fact on her
Instagram story because she put up a
picture of her necklace that said Bieber
and like a little bit of a cold sore on
her lip yep I noticed it because you can
I get them cuz Margaret's cold sore
Queen I'm cold sore Queen and she
doesn't mean it's herpes by the way
Marco gets close but it's technically
herpes but it's just not the STD Marco's
cold sores like from Scherzer and the
weather as our resident cold don't you
just move to Canada and it's probably
shock to her system with the what cold
weather so she's got a cold sore
turns out that's that's your analysis
yeah makes total sense but do you think
it's a cold sore like yours or well hard
on her top lip but I've never gotten
them there so it's a little different
Wow snitch can you um can you diagnose
can you give a prescription yeah get
some valtrex
and some lysine pills okay thank you
Margo Thank You snitch for your expert
analysis um when they were going by the
way this story like just makes me feel
even more strong in my resolve that my
little sister must h on men those yeah
because now not only is he looking for a
girl thank God he's looking for a girl
who's like really outwardly sexy to to
once again prove he's not gay so like
that's Eva to show your titties girl I
got it I think you guys would be the
cutest couple
I mean e-to if you could just like give
it you know know if he just like would
be like somewhat possible to reach ya
know he's so unattainable he's so
[ __ ] famous like who I don't know
mine cries himself to sleep I don't know
anyone that I could like get you Intel
like I don't know I have a single link i
watch oh yes of course I think you could
find one no I don't even know who was
like manager is like I but maybe like
once you find out you'll find the link
or if anyone hears like related to Shawn
Mendes hook us up right that's him
what do you think is the best shot in
this song a my fun me too also something
big which is like his first song it's so
good you're smiling also life is a party
from that album illuminate so good so
yeah big ah feel it happening out of my
control
pushing anyways so here at the toast we
are reformed then we will respect Shawn
Mendes as much yes sometimes it's like I
start to feel badly about like all the
[ __ ] I talk yeah it's my job and I don't
mean to be in a negative way it's just
like speculation but then sometimes I'm
like damn these are real people like
what people say we really need [ __ ]
about me I'm like oh my god that hurts
my feelings and like that's what Shawn
Mendes feels but then I'm also like okay
I'm not Sharma it's like when you're so
rich and famous and money like that
helps you forget the mean things people
say about you right so if I had is
enough I find the same amount of money
fame and just like beloved like diehard
fans as char Mendes did like I wouldn't
care the people are calling me fat do
you know any mean but I don't have that
yet so I care very fair maybe if someone
gave me more money
okay our fifth and final story I'm
switching it up from celebrity news to
just something interesting because so
many toasts er said that they were so
thankful at Thanksgiving like obviously
for the toasts but because of all the
business stories that we share they
really felt like they had so much to say
at their Thanksgiving table and that
people were really impressed so I feel
even stronger in my resolve this isn't a
business story but just an interesting
story an interesting factoid of course
we're just full of interesting factors
you called the morning interesting
factoid in order to really call the
morning important important pertinent
information yeah maybe we'll change the
name most popular baby names for 2018
I love these stories oh let me guess
okay boys or girls or Zappos both okay
separate lists so separate lists that's
so funny that they still do that you
know yeah okay for a girl you're not
gonna guess I don't know you might guess
the number two like guess one out of the
top five you might guess two of them
okay
unless you've never looked highly no
unless you've never looked at one of
these lists but whoever idea yes yeah
Olivia is number two okay so for girls
Sophia celebrates her 9 the executive
year as the top choice for girls while
Jackson remains in the knows the most
popular name for boys running or
worldwide Ivan I think this would be
America so for girls if one Sophia to
Olivia
three Emma for Ava that's really
surprising five Isabella
I love the name is about what I love the
name a about these are all beautiful
names you guys were doing a great job
six Aria seven I think that actually has
a lot to do with Game of Thrones two and
thirty little liars six Arya seven Riley
eight Emilia nine Mia ten Laila
you I'm gonna keep going no it's just so
funny cuz like I feel like of all the
names that we have in our family Olivia
is the most beautiful and the most
special and it's like the most popular
but I don't know that many Olivia's and
I feel like every time I meet in Olivia
it's like a cool girl and she's unique
like but it's also not unique because
it's the number one name do you know
what I mean yeah I think now a lot of
babies are being named Olivia but like
the Olivia's of our generation were
pioneers we're parents were pioneers the
Capo's and the entrees right and I said
this to love me before but everyone who
I know named Olivia just like it's a
winner's name yeah I would be Olivia's
you know um Olivia culpo
Olivia ashtray Olivia newton-john she's
a real woman she's a real winner and I
just feel like there's no lose like if
you name your kid a lip well now the
odds are against you but at a time like
if in the 90s if you named your kid
Olivia like you were gonna raise a smart
winner so what's the next Olivia look
that people are being names now spur a
delay let's look at some of the the
names lower Neela
Charlotte Harper sounds like Charlotte
is on its way down you know why Lily
Chloe Alya Adeline Evelyn Avery Aubrey
Ella I always thought when I would have
kids I would look at these names and be
inspired hmm I like the name Ella but if
it's short for something LaBella
actually I have a great name to be
shortened don't say it I'm not going to
Camila
Norah scarlet Maya Emily okay what about
boys boys one Jackson - Liam three Noah
for eighth in a lot of sex in the Sun he
loves the name Noah I love all these
names on it and I love the name Jackson
I can't name my kid Jackson because my
name is Jackie thank you though if oh my
god I watched an episode of baby twins
Jackie and Jackson Jackie I watched an
episode
I need toasters I'm pregnant with twins
go for it I watched an episode of house
hunters
tonight and it was this couple his name
was Dodd and I forgot the wife's name
because she was so goddamn annoying but
they were looking for a house in winter
Ville Georgia and he was the mayor of
winter and they were like so cute he's
like I have to stay within the city
limits and they were so caring about the
ugly house yeah when he was second I'm
mayor and I was like what I watch the
most incredible episode of shark tank
last night okay from the new season okay
and there's a new shark he is
he runs a venture capital firm and he's
the vice president of the Miami Dolphin
so I was like how do you get to be that
and they did his profile it's the same I
don't know his name can you look up new
shark but I am a Dolphins so he started
he grew up really poor in New York and
Queens I think and he like Matt Higgins
Matt Higgins he worked hot yeah that's
his way like through high school he like
dropped out of high school to get his
GED and then went to college and took
the night classes to study at Fordham
Law like and like get his law degree as
quickly as possible because was also
taking care of his mom he became the
press secretary for New York State and
during the time of 9/11 so he then
became the CEO of the rebuilding of the
Freedom Tower and involved in the 9/11
cleanup and from there he just like
that's what catapulted his career now
he's the vice president Miami Dolphins
and he invests in startups any notable
investments yes milk bar what's milk bar
what is everything okay oh you know what
it is it's that does our place oh no way
yeah and so and then there's also this
other pizza company that looks delicious
it looks like premium like gourmet
that's a lot of fashion casual I believe
okay anyways there was one group family
that came in with the saddest story no
don't tell me because I saw everyone
talking about in the toast they were and
I want to watch it I don't want to know
anything about it so please don't tell
them oh my god now I won't say what it
was but I just want to say like that
those kids yeah thank you for the
airdrop says Matt Higgins that's his
picture cutie cutie business madness and
he was so respectful of to Ben Ben she
was Doris Michael of all the
entrepreneurs he made like a lot of good
deals and I just wanna say like this
these kids were
the whole thing is so moving and the
product is amazing and even if I never
use in mind I think I'm gonna buy one
just because I want to support it I just
wanna say I saw you watching shark tank
on your story and I bought something
that was on their tata towel and it
hasn't arrived and it's annoying me
because it'll change my life when it
does arrive but I don't know if it's
ever coming cuz I auditor from the
jenkees website
well that was an incredible invention
that woman the genius the game and I
really think that they should sponsor
the toes because I would sit here in a
towel that would be so funny what would
you ever pants like like I want and wear
one I weren't all around my house oh of
course I just want to know if you can
adjust like the cabinet later vibe
because I need my tips to perk up on the
house there were women on TV wearing
tags like she had like four models and
they were big breasted women because
it's for a break breasted women cuz
small women and they don't have that
like cider under right anyways I love
bra I'm gonna have shark tank
Bethany's on this next one I'm sure they
really do a great job of finding
interesting people and they keep the
ones who are good sometimes people come
on and they're just like not sharks
they're just like rich people and
there's a difference like Richard
Branson I was not into him whatsoever
and he was really buying for Mark
Cuban's like King vibe and I was an
interpreter Branson I just watched one
with Charles Barkley who is a bloomin
athlete and I didn't I mean I've
obviously know his name but I'm not you
know renowned in the world of sports and
I was so impressed by him and his story
and his appreciation and gratitude and
his humbleness like mother makes me
wanna watch it so bad I was just so
impressed with his mindset he's approach
to life after my life changes meeting
time so today I'm gonna dive right in
dive right is just like I have not
started with houses in New Jersey I'm
behind on Dallas
I'm behind on OC I am behind on shots I
am behind on [ __ ] everything and I
just can't stop watching reruns a
fixer-upper like that's my life I said
last night I am caught up on everything
I'm caught up on OC I am caught up on
Dallas I am caught up on New Jersey I am
caught up on Kardashians and I don't
know where I've been doing them on my
car because next week pump girls next
week I've been saying my thoughts and my
stories but like I have so many thoughts
and you don't want to like I'm not gonna
bore you good this week I will do it
we have a plane ride we have it's a
[ __ ] connecting flight in Birmingham
Alabama there's only 24 tickets dude so
funny this is why I love the toasters
over this de buncha shows a couple
months ago and I got on the phone with
my team and they're like we think you
should cancel Hoover like nobody about
tickets and I'm like what Alabama was
like my place and I was like really
upset and I was like okay but like give
it a week there's 24 tickets left and
it's a huge venue so thank you toasters
for always bullying third for me by the
last 24 tickets do it we're all tied and
the only the GAF so it's 25 bucks like
20 bucks for a good time and me murder
were totally hittin the town afterwards
yeah 25 bucks for a great time it's some
drinks laughter is the best medicine and
all you have to pay for it is $25 no
copay oh could I show you something no
copay December 4th
what have the TPG on the show and
personal we're gonna do such a great
show with him because I don't want us I
don't wanna get anyone too excited okay
December 4th at night are also the TPG
Awards which are gonna be so prestigious
like he's telling me some of the plenty
like it's literally the same budget as a
Grammy I'm wearing a ball gown nope but
he's coming on the fourth slice talking
about that Ward shows and he's also
gonna give away two tickets to show
stars who live in New York so that's
really exciting or toasters food or
lemon New York and can make it to New
York by nighttime and he's gives you a
whole helpful thing with credit cards
because we released our Kemp chose
tickets and we gave you a weeks notice
next week December 3rd they're going
live forever on December 2nd for patron
members and for cam toast oh gee first
cam toast attendees and some of the
young toasters are like damn and each
open a credit card I'm a TBG this would
actually be helpful like you're here
December 4th tickets go on sale the day
after like let's do a whole thing of it
down to cards
sorry yeah let's still holding on credit
cards like a safe way to open a credit
card if you like me to buy a camcos
ticket so he's gonna revolutionize our
finances but the reason why I'm saying
this is because you're obsessed with TPG
I know is because so I'm presenting an
award I blow cheated words Oh best lay
flat bed for first class because he
knows I like love life Abed we that's so
cute that those are the awards you know
it's really like an Heather McMahon is
sitting on our table and Heather McMahon
is coming on and she's coming on the
toast December 6 it's like a whole TPG
family I was thinking about Heather
McManus hos I think we should do the
whole show the three of us done I'm so
excited
um it's gonna be impossible for you to
get a word I know and I actually thought
the same thing and I so I'm here to
moderate okay it's a panel
I'm the moderator with two comedians and
actresses so she's presenting and then
I'm presenting afterwards and they had
me do because a lot of my show is about
travel there can you do a five minute
stick of like and I've never done like
us five minutes I do my whole show and
like I'm just I'm so nervous don't be
nervous because like that's so much
easier than what you normally do and
your travel like you could talk about
good there's a lot of airline bigwigs in
the audience by the way if we want to
get our private jet it's gonna be there
and I also just want to get my miles for
my divine version that's literally all I
need also I don't know I don't wanna get
in trouble for saying where it is but
it's at the intrepid it's at in the
intro I know it's gonna be still the jet
I'm so excited I'm so sad to have them
on the show because I haven't been on
the show with him since the first time
the first time I learned so much and now
that I have all these like on the first
show I learned how to get points and I
have a boys and now I'm gonna learn how
to spend my points and it's like so
funny cuz we were away this weekend like
how many times did I talk about the
points guy know so many times that's why
I just said because you're obsessing
because we were sitting around like
silent staring at the fire you know
tress on Soros saying do you get out the
tbg mode no and then one time you were
like did you know that I'm obsessed EDG
well I just think his business is so
impressive and every time I learned
something new about him like these
awards like it's it's gonna be it's
literally gonna be the same like
budget-ass Grammys that's insane
I'm working we're gonna be there and we
set to retail oh I made it so it's the
scenes John Eric Simon and Phil Heather
and plus-one I think they talents aliens
come oh my god I'm so excited
I know me and Heather said we're gonna
while she's in New Yorker and take a
trip to Lourdes Taylor before closest if
you want to come
oh thanks I'll be there um do you wanna
know the rest of the mail baby names no
okay I'll just look I've still moved on
I'm gonna take you now Kate and Grayson
Lucas Mason Oliver ohio's Mason of
course Mason so my breasts well I can't
spell from he's so paranoid about my
breath because Tom Selleck because I'm
going to the bluebloods said like I just
want to be the girl like I was gonna be
like the girl who's annoying and like
energetic but I don't wanna be the girl
who's energetic annoying and has bad
breath
Swiss stole a bunch of mints from the
set here and I also brush my teeth with
a new toothbrush this morning so like
maybe maybe that will help the new
toothbrush have we just got burst births
roll care toothbrushes that have you
know they plug in the work they're legit
like there's the one who you see just
use like an toothbrush from the
drugstore like it's
evolutionary and it's like actually like
feels different and did you never
suppose musher dude for two minutes yeah
for like 10 seconds I'm like damn that
was long I brush my teeth until the
toothpaste runs out this one has a timer
so it's like oh you're done [ __ ] it
doesn't say that it should but it
doesn't you can program it to say that I
know first step is like a little weirded
out cuz when I opened it the bristles
are black then I read in the box it's
there infused with charcoal but you
obviously those girls on Instagram
brushing their teeth of charcoal and it
works so now I'm an Instagram girl with
my charcoal teeth and my good breath
you're brushing them twice a day with
charcoal which is incredible also people
don't realize about me I have an amazing
smile
but I have terrible teeth yes your top
is perfect no not I'm sorry books they
look incredible it's like your home
looks impeccable so many issues I check
out this tooth back you know okay I've
had a root canal I've had my wisdom
teeth out I've had over 12 cavities it's
because you're not using Burstall now
that I'm using birth so ah I'm so
excited to really infuse my teeth with
charcoal also Ben is like always
unplugging my [ __ ] in the bathroom and
it's so annoying so if you charge that
thing once it lasts for [ __ ] like for
four weeks no it's amazing
and much like third love they have a fit
finder quiz which just really feels so
personal and tailored to me all you have
to do is answer a few simple questions
to find your fit they just came out with
a rose gold color color toothbrush and
it's truly is gorgeous and it comes in a
little travel case too so you can take
it on the go I'm gonna keep I have two
now two births ones so one for my
bathroom and then one for my travel case
even though it's important to have two
separate toothbrushes because if you
travel a lot like taking it in and out
of your suitcase like that's disgusting
no I agree
oh I'm sorry they don't have anybody go
to burst or CARICOM to get your limited
rose gold burst Sonicare toothbrush and
use our code toast at checkout to get
10% off your order
that's burst oil CARICOM with Koto's for
10% off don't miss out on this special
offer go to burst orichalcum today and
don't forget to enter our code toast for
10% off the news rural school toothbrush
rose gold tooth brush say that 10 times
they also send you a new head every
three months cuz like apparently you're
supposed to change your toothbrush which
is i've been using the same toothbrush
truly for ten years really I always like
in the back of my mind I never did this
when I was like two thirty simply should
be almost disposable they're disgusting
and so I'm so grateful
for this subscription because I no
longer feel wasteful like I'm not gonna
throw away my whole toothbrush just the
toothbrush head so they send you a new
head in the mail you don't even have to
think about it and good and it's only
seven dollars first or CARICOM code test
also there's a master post in our
Facebook group with all the codes that
we have just because like I feel like
there's a lot of brands that the chose
to use toasters regularly and you should
be able to find it so make sure to go
find it also we've gotten so many
requests about getting in facebook group
and we are we're moving on it it's just
super hard because once you just like
letting influx of people and like it's
mayhem with the rural super slowly
trying to let like ten people in a day
one by one also the easiest way to get
into the group is actually to join the
patreon join the patreon group and then
I can sort like page our members get
into the may get into the patreon group
and then into the main group
automatically right so once you're in
the patron group which is much easier to
get into what you slide right into the
morning testers right which is really
nice so that's one way or you could just
be patient have amazing answers continue
to apply regularly because sometimes
I'll do like mass let ins in order of
newest first please don't tell me your
friend's name because I can't search
names so that's not helpful just tell
your friend when I do a post in the toe
steers head I'm letting people head and
tell your friend rely that's the best I
can do for you yeah it's so it's so hard
Facebook needs to come up with a better
way but I don't think probably Facebook
groups are built for like community
building but they need to come up with
better ways to administrate right we're
doing the best that we can though we
have now everyone is on board knows the
the questionnaire process yeah also chem
toast we've just been like planning for
so long look people are so shocked the
tickets are available so far in advance
but it's like first of all I think that
we did it now just because a lot of
people want like their husband's mom's
to buy it for a Christmas gift and this
is the perfect timing one and two it's
like I want everyone to be able to let
we were so haphazard the last time
because like we were just we didn't the
summer to end we were rush but we just
wanted to do it now it's like [ __ ]
people a whole year of planning like
it's gonna be the most well thought-out
weekend of your life and you need to
know if you're going to camp totes like
did you get a ticket are you coming so
you can plan so the days it's Memorial
Day weekend of 2019 so it's the Friday
to the Monday I don't know the exact
dates do you um know but you know what
there's an easy way to find out
calendar Memorial Day 2019 I feel like
it's 24
2:27 um so it's May 27th yes so Monday
May 27 26 25 24 24 7 May 24 27 tickets
don't go on sale December 3rd if you are
having any questions posting the main
group because there are about a hundred
people who went last year and they have
all your questions answered Renee
Miranda may Elana so just like you're
good yeah and then there will be a camp
host to group for everyone who does get
tickets tickets go on sale Monday
December 3rd right after we wrap the
show but they go on presale for patreon
members and original campers of camp
toast 1:00 on Sunday December 2nd at
noon eastern time so gir dear [ __ ]
loins and if you really really really
really really want to tick in and want
to confirm that you're gonna get one
join the patreon like that's my tip of
the day tip of the day just the tip
patreon.com Sasha morning toast and then
you get also in addition to the pre-sale
and an entry into the group you get
access to all of our patreon episodes
which are so like I want to just go back
and listen to our first ones cuz we
really just riff off of your questions
and talk about like personal stories
like I remember when we did that episode
about like crushes because someone
brought it up in the green I feel like I
tapped into memories I haven't thought
about in years on our patreon episodes
because we source questions from the
group and they like go deep yeah and
they ask really interesting questions
that prompt us to think differently than
we do on this show so it really is
personal and hilarious and I think you
really enjoy it if you're looking for
some for some additional premium content
I just don't want the show I can't
believe we did it in an hour what sort
of bad but should I go for one meeting
Tom Selleck [ __ ] like his mustache no oh
my god you're like a meeting chair no I
was think about this last night like we
don't go in for the hug I think we shake
his hand I don't but the shooting is yes
we're gonna meet him cuz like we're not
really there to see him what we're not
like we're there to just observe and I
spoke to Jenko and she like obviously
she's cool but like Tom Selleck doesn't
know who you are so like unless let me
go over there and be obnoxious which I
don't want it I don't want to not get
invited back no and I'm sure be
obnoxious we can just go over to and be
like hey we're huge fans like it doesn't
have to be so crazy we can't not say how
much they got a photo I mean my owner
said he's Richard from friends like he's
also the commissioners yeah yeah yeah
Shmi Bob telling me like this and we'll
wait for him to be like as you were
he'll probably think you're
like extras well I said it's weird we're
going to a scene because there's so many
people in the cast they very rarely all
film together unless they're having
family dinner which is why we're going
to this specific scene but in family
dinner there's no extras but if we were
like the street they would let us just
walk right like if it was a crime scene
you should set that up - yeah just as
being an extra like I just want to like
be one of the people in his office who's
like kushner there's three [ __ ] here
it's like there was a dead body on the
street and we're all like behind let me
be in the beginning you and I are like
going for a jog well maybe not jug a
stroll
no more like if they're walking down the
street and then you're just walking like
across right no no but I discover the
body and I'm like nobody me and my girl
power ball came like yeah can you
believe what you said about me on the
show yesterday Wow can you know the
morning tell my god I fell into this
podcast wait was it Supergirl call scene
I mean this is just like one order
extended watch blue bugs which is why I
wasn't invited scene I felt like this
podcast called the morning shows have
you heard that now what is that wow it's
so great there's like two girls they're
super cute skinny funny gorgeous and
they're really stopping and they
basically just like sit every morning
for like a couple hours and just like
talk about the [ __ ] that I really care
about they call themselves the
Millennial morning show it's really
really good wow that's such a hard job
they must be super talented no they're
so talented so beautiful did I mention
that and super sorry me gay of the
morning toasteen speaking in the morning
to those the lady gang oh my god we
haven't done the show in so long okay
the Sunday before we left for our trip
our lives were changed literally the
cord lady gang I was like a minute light
and someone wrote in the toasters
grouping they were like freaking out
they said morning toast on legging and
they showed our set like our little set
I was like like our little set with our
morning toast logo on the left and the e
logo on top of it I was like what
so I went back and rewind it on my DVR
and basically they were recapping out of
recap and it was like okay so what we
said we said it was such an amazing show
and that we're living for like the whole
day stark contrast inside show better
that yeah yeah but we were like I said
they all play this is what I said my
recap was all positive and I was
they all really play a role except I
can't figure out the girl Jacqueline
Jack Jack Jack Jack I can't figure out
her own like she was like annoying me a
little bit but like I really look I
didn't mean it in a negative way and
like I was just saying so many positive
things about a show that technically is
our competitor like I say one negative
thing and I've lived on that girl and
I'm sorry I apologize so what that girl
was saying on the show she was like you
know actually Kelsey I want to they have
a segment good week bad week so I had a
bad week because like you highlighted
this week hub that we did and the girls
like didn't say nice things about me and
Kelsey I was like no they did like it
was just like a sacred mysteries which
is really how we how we do feel you know
it wasn't negative it was just like I
don't I have engaged her vibe yet right
and I look like I know Beca because I'm
a Gleek and I know Kelsey because she's
the host in that she makes her role
known did you know that Kathy was on The
Bachelor know what season I'd like a
wipe maybe like Jake Pavelka or
something like before we watch isn't
that interesting
berry and look what she's done now she's
unnie and brother my shows it's CGS oh
the things even deep red Wow
but like bigger bachelor success story
that's like on par with [ __ ] Jesse
Palmer yeah TV
she's Sadie game their success and I got
their little box it was just so cute and
now I just like love that I'm like we're
like Lady gangers yeah yeah I'm bringing
mangers and then they call them some
litigators ladies or something oh yeah
yeah that makes sense yes
well the shout out and they just hope
your show gets picked up and they hope
like having to go after the worst show
on TV isn't hurting your ratings agree
also I want someone needs such a good
call the fact that busy tonight is on
four nights a week makes no sense just
given the name it's like busy tonight
and nightly pop which seems like the
name offers like a week like a daily
show happens every night and it makes no
sense
do you wonder something so funny in the
first episode it's such a funny show and
I have it recorded I'm gonna cut it off
of nightly pop so Morgan who really
Helms the show on the first episode at
the end they do like funny little bits
at the end each each episode and she
walks through the e Studios and she goes
into a room where Khloe Kardashian is
and I guess they have like this funny
banter and Morgan psych
so like do you want to come on my show
nightly pop and Chloe's like being so
standoffish she was like oh sure I'll
come tomorrow night and she was like
well it's just Mondays it's a little
confusing it is she was
you would think Knightly Knightly he's
on Mondays it was so they addressed it
definitely like hoping to eventually a
test I played a play-by-play it's so
funny because for so long he was so not
in tune with what was necessary in terms
of their content I couldn't get a
reality show to work for more than one
season if they're like [ __ ] dependent
on it and it's like I don't know who
they hired but like they're getting
better well they're also throwing so
much [ __ ] against the wall that
something's bound to stick no nightly
pop is good daily pop is good busy
tonight no but they can will be when
there's late again good yeah
what else did he's like from friends me
good custard good I've seen it
understand like a princess it's like
custard good okay good
me yeah I would maybe watch friends if
they do a read not a reboot but they're
never gonna know if they reproduce it
like and take out the laugh track maybe
I'll watch I hate Alaska 10:35 then I
have to go see Blue Bloods so thank you
guys for tuning in let me so much we're
back tomorrow and the day after we began
Friday right yes we have a geeking out
Carolyn from she's a youtuber she's a
toaster her YouTube videos taught me how
to use presets and she's gonna be coming
on the show just to get us all into
what's necessary and she's gonna blog us
so hopefully will become YouTube famous
overnight can't wait see you guys
tomorrow tomorrow I love ya tomorrow
always know you're always a day you
[ __ ] up I harmonize to perfection
goodbye everyone
you